Eel 10 de Septiembre, la mañana de mi séptimo cumpleaños,
bajé las escaleras a la cocina, donde mi madre estaba lavando los platos
y mi padre estaba leyendo el periódico o algo así,
hice una especie de saludo desde el umbral de la puerta, y dijeron,
"¡Eh, feliz cumpleaños!" Y yo dije, "tengo siete años."
Mi padre sonrió y dijo,
"Bueno, ya sabes lo que eso significa, ¿no?"
Y yo dije, "Sí, ¿que voy a tener una fiesta y pastel
y obtendré muchos regalos?" Y mi papá dijo, "Bueno, sí.
Pero algo más importante que eso, tener siete años significa que has llegado a la edad de la razón,
y ahora puedes cometer todos y cada uno de los pecados contra Dios y la humanidad."
(Risas)
Ya había escuchado esa frase, "la edad de la razón," anteriormente.
La hermana Mary Kevin había hablado al respecto
en mi clase de segundo grado. Pero cuando ella lo decía,
la frase parecía estar envuelta en la emoción de los preparativos
para nuestra primera comunión y nuestra primera confesión,
y todo mundo sabía que el chiste de todo eso era usar el vestido blanco con velo,
aunque de todas formas, no le había prestado atención a esa frase, "la edad de la razón."
Así que dije, "Sí, sí, la edad de la razón. ¿Y eso que quería decir?"
Y mi papá dijo, "Bueno, nosotros los católicos creemos
que Dios sabe que los niños pequeños no notan la diferencia entre el bien y el mal,
pero cuando cumples siete, ya estás grandecita para distinguirlo.
Así que ya eres grande y has llegado a la edad de la razón, y ahora
Dios empezará a anotar lo que hagas en tu expediente permanente."
(Risas)
Y yo dije, "Oh. Un momento. O sea que durante todo este tiempo,
hasta hoy, me he portado tan bien y Dios no lo ha notado?"
Y mi mamá dijo, "Pero yo sí."
(Risas)
Y yo pensé, "¿Cómo no lo supe antes?
¿Cómo no me entró en la cabeza cuando me estuvieron diciendo?
Tanto portarme bien y sin recibir crédito por ello.
Y lo peor, ¿Cómo no me di cuenta de esta información tan importante
hasta el día en que me era prácticamente inútil?
Así que dije, "Mamá, Papá, ¿y qué hay de Santa Clós?
Quiero decir, Santa sabe si he sido buena o mala, ¿no?
Y mi papá dijo, "Sí, pero, cariño,
Creo que eso es técnicamente sólo entre el Día de Acción de Gracias y Navidad."
Y mi mamá dijo, "Oh, Bob, basta. Vamos a decírselo.
Ya tiene siete años. Julie, Santa Clós no existe."
(Risas)
En realidad, esto no me molestó especialmente.
Mis padres contaban esta complicada historia sobre Santa Clós:
ellos habían hablado con el mismísimo Santa Clós y acordaron
que en vez de que él trajera los regalos durante la Nochebuena,
como lo hacía con todas las otras familias
que podían abrir sus regalos a primera hora de la mañana de Navidad,
nuestra familia le daría a Santa más tiempo.
Santa vendría a nuestra casa mientras estábamos en la misa de las nueve
en la mañana de navidad, pero sólo si no nos quejábamos.
Lo que me hizo sospechar.
Era bastante obvio que nuestros padres nos daban los regalos.
Me explico: mi papá tenía una forma peculiar de envolver,
y la letra de mi mamá era tan parecida a la de Santa.
Además, ¿por qué Santa ahorraría tiempo al tener que regresar
a nuestra casa después de haber ido a la de todos los demás?
Sólo hay una conclusión obvia a la que se llega con esta pila de evidencia:
nuestra familia era demasiado rara
incluso para que Santa Clós viniera a visitarnos,
y mis pobres padres estaban tratando de protegernos de la vergüenza,
de la humillación del rechazo de Santa, quien era alegre.
Pero, aceptémoslo, también era un juzgón.
Así que, descubrir que no existía Santa Clós fue una especie de alivio.
Me fui de la cocina, no tanto en estado de shock por lo de Santa,
sino que más bien no sabía qué decir
sobre cómo podía haberme perdido todo esto de la edad de la razón.
Ya era muy tarde para mi, pero tal vez podría ayudar a alguien más,
alguien que pudiera usar la información.
Debían cumplir dos criterios:
ser suficientemente grandes para entender
el concepto de la edad de la razón, y no tener siete años todavía.
La respuesta era simple: mi hermano Bill. Él tenía seis.
Bueno, finalmente encontré a Bill como a una cuadra de la casa
en el patio de la escuela. Era sábado,
y estaba solo, pateando una pelota contra la pared.
Corrí a él y le dije, "¡Bill!"
me acabo de dar cuenta de que la edad de la razon empieza cuando cumples siete años,
y entonces ya eres capaz de cometer todo tipo de pecados
contra Dios y la humanidad." Y Bill dijo, "¿y luego?" Y le dije,
"Pues, tú tienes seis. Tienes todo un año para hacer lo que quieras
y Dios no se dará cuenta." Y él dijo, "¿Y qué?" Y le dije,
"¿Cómo que y qué? ¡Y qué todo!" Me di la vuelta corriendo, estaba tan enojada con él.
Pero cuando llegué al último escalón, me di vuelta dramáticamente
y dije, "Por cierto, Bill, no existe Santa Clós."
(Risas)
Bueno, yo no lo sabía entonces,
pero en realidad no cumplía siete años el 10 de septiembre.
Para mi décimo tercero cumpleaños, planeé una fiesta de pijamas con mis amigas,
pero unas semanas antes mi madre me llamó y dijo,
"Necesito hablar contigo, en privado.
El 10 de septiembre no es tu cumpleaños. Es el 10 de octubre." Y dije, "¿Qué?"
(Risas)
Y dijo, "Mira, la fecha límite para entrar al Jardín de Niños era el 15 de septiembre."
"Así que les dije que tu cumpleaños era el 10 de septiembre,
y como no estaba segura de que no fueras a ir con el chisme por todas partes,
te empecé a decir que tu cumpleaños era el 10 de septiembre.
Pero Julie, ya estabas lista para ir a la escuela, cariño. Estabas lista."
Ahora que lo pienso, cuando tenía cuatro años
ya era la mayor de cuatro niños,
y mi madre estaba embarazada de otro,
así que creo que lo que quería decir, no sin razón, es que ella estaba lista,
ella estaba lista. Entonces dijo,
"No te preocupes, Julie, todos los años el 10 de octubre, cuando era tu cumpleaños
pero no lo sabías, me aseguré
de que comieras un pedazo de pastel ese día."
(Risas)
Lo que era reconfortante, pero confuso.
Mi madre había estado clebrando mi cumpleaños conmigo, sin mí.
Lo que más me molestó de esta nueva información
no era que tendría que cambiar la fecha de mi fiesta
con todas mis amigas,
lo que era más molesto es que eso significaba que no era virgo.
Tenía un gran póster de virgo en mi cuarto,
y leía mi horóscopo todos los días sin falta, y me describía completamente.
(Risas)
¿Y eso significaba que era libra?
Entonces, tomé el autobús al centro para comprar el póster de libra.
El de virgo tenía la imagen de una hermosa mujer con el cabello largo,
como reposando cerca del agua,
mientras que el póster de libra era una balanza gigante.
Eso ocurrió cuando estaba cambiando físicamente,
y estaba cambiando mucho más que las otras niñas,
y, francamente, la idea de que mi signo astrológico fuera una báscula
simplemente parecía siniestro y deprimente.
(Risas)
Pero conseguí el nuevo póster de libra,
y empecé a leer mi nuevo horóscopo,
y quedé asombrada al descubrir que también me describía completamente.
No fue sino hasta años después, al ver en retrospectiva
todo esto de la-edad-de-la-razón/cambio-de-cumpleaños,
que me di cuenta de que no cumplía siete
cuando pensé que cumplía siete. Tenía todo un mes más
para hacer lo que quisiera antes de que Dios empezara a etiquetarme.
¡Ay!, la vida puede ser tan cruel.
Un día, dos misioneros mormones vinieron a mi puerta.
Vivo junto a una pista en Los Ángeles,
y mi cuadra es --bueno, es un inicio natural
para la gente que va de puerta en puerta.
A veces llegan viejitas de la iglesia Adventista del séptimo día
enseñándome estas ilustraciones del cielo.
Y en ocasiones llegan adolescentes que prometen que no se unirán a una pandilla
y que no robarán si les compro
una suscripción a una revista.
Así que normalmente ignoro el timbre, pero ese día abrí la puerta.
Y había dos chicos, como de 19 años cada uno,
con sus camisitas blancas y almidonadas de manga corta, con etiquetas con su nombre
que los identificaban como representantes oficiales
de la Iglesia de Jesucristo de los Santos de los Últimos Días,
y me dijeron que tenían un mensaje para mi de parte de Dios.
Y dije, "¿Un mensaje para mi? ¿de parte de Dios?" Y dijeron, "Sí."
Yo fui criada en el Pacífico Noroeste,
rodeada de muchas Iglesias de los Santos de los Últimos Días,
he trabajado con ellos, incluso he salido con alguno,
pero nunca conocí su doctrina o lo que le decían a la gente
cuando iban en misiones, así que supongo que tenía cierta curiosidad,
así que dije, "Bueno, por favor, entren." Y se veían muy felices,
porque no creo que les ocurra demasiado a menudo.
(Risas)
Los senté y les di vasos con agua --
OK, lo tengo. Les di vasos con agua.
No toques mi cabello, esa es la cuestión.
(Risas)
No puedes poner un video mío en frente de mi
y esperar que no me arregle el cabello.
(Risas)
OK. Entonces los senté y les di vasos con agua,
y tras unas palabras amables, dijeron, "¿Crees que Dios te ama con todo su corazón?"
Y pensé, "Bueno, por supuesto que creo en Dios,
pero, no me gusta esa palabra, "corazón",
porque hace muy humano a Dios,
y no me gusta la palabra "suyo" [de él], porque sexualiza a Dios."
Pero no quería discutir sobre semántica con estos chicos,
así que después de una larga e incómoda pausa, dije
"Sí, sí, me siento muy amada."
Se vieron uno al otro y sonrieron,
como si fuera la respuesta correcta. Y luego dijeron,
"¿Crees que todos somos hermanos y hermanas en este planeta?"
Y yo dije, "Sí, lo creo." Y me sentí aliviada
de que fuera una pregunta que podía contestar tan rápido.
Y luego dijeron, "bueno, entonces te contaremos una historia."
Y me contaron la historia de este tipo llamado Lehi,
quien vivió en Jerusalén 600 años A.C.
Al parecer en Jerusalén en el año 600 A.C.
todos eran totalmente malos y perversos. Todos y cada uno de ellos:
hombres, mujeres, niños, infantes, fetos.
Y Dios se acercó a Lehi y le dijo, "Pon a tu familia en una barca
y te guiaré fuera de aquí." Y Dios los guió.
Los guió a América.
Yo dije, "¿América? ¿Desde Jerusalén hasta América en barca en el año 600 A.C.?"
Y ellos dijeron, "Sí."
(Risas)
Luego me contaron que Lehi y sus descendientes
se reprodujeron y reprodujeron, y en el transcurso de 600 años
se desarrollaron dos grandes razas de ellos, los Nefitas y los Lamanitas,
los Nefitas eran total y completamente buenos -- todos y cada uno de ellos--
y los Lamanitas eran total y completamente malos --
todos y cada uno de ellos, malos hasta la médula.
(Risas)
Luego de que Jesús muriera en la cruz por nuestros pecados,
en su camino al cielo se detuvo en América y visitó a los Nefitas.
(Risas)
Y les dijo que si todos permanecían total y completamente buenos --
todos y cada uno de ellos--
podrían ganar la guerra contra los malignos Lamanitas.
Pero al parecer alguien lo echó a perder,
porque los Lamanitas pudieron matar a todos los Nefitas.
A todos menos a uno, este tipo llamado Mormón,
quien logró sobrevivir escondiéndose en el bosque.
Y se aseguró de que toda esta historia se escribiera
en jeroglíficos egipcios reformados grabados en platos de oro,
que fueron enterrados en Palmyra, Nueva York.
(Risas)
Bueno, yo estaba al borde de mi asiento.
Les dije, "¿Qué pasó con los Lamanitas?"
Y me dijeron, "Bueno, ellos se volvieron nuestros nativos americanos, aquí en EE.UU."
Y dije, "Entonces, ustedes creen que los nativos americanos descienden
de unas personas que eran totalmente malas?" Y dijeron, "Sí."
Entonces me contaron que este tipo llamado Joseph Smith
encontró enterrados esos platos de oro en su patio trasero,
y que también encontró esta piedra mágica ahí mismo, que ponía en su sombrero.
Y entonces metía la cabeza en él y eso le permitía
traducir los platos de oro del egipcio reformado al inglés.
Bueno, para entonces ya quería darle a estos chicos
algún consejo sobre su tirada.
(Risas)
Quería decirles, "OK, no empiecen con esa historia."
O sea, incluso los cienciólogos saben que hay que hacer un test de personalidad antes de empezar--
(Aplauso)
--a decirle a las personas todo sobre Xenu, el maligno señor intergaláctico.
Luego dijeron, "¿Crees que Dios nos habla
a través de sus rectos profetas?" Y les dije, "No, no lo creo."
Porque estaba como molesta por esta historia de los Lamanitas
y la de ese plato dorado, pero la verdad,
no lo había pensado tanto, así que di marcha atrás un poco y dije,
"Bueno, ¿qué quieren decir con rectos?
¿Y qué quieren decir con profetas? Es decir, ¿los profetas pueden ser mujeres?
Y dijeron, "No." Y dije, "¿Por qué? Y dijeron,
"Bueno, porque Dios le dio a las mujeres un don tan espectacular,
tan maravilloso, que el único don que le quedaba para dar a los hombres
era el don de la profecía."
¿Cuál es ese maravilloso don que le dio Dios a las mujeres?, me preguntaba yo
¿Tal vez su mejor habilidad para adaptarse y cooperar?
¿Mayor esperanza de vida? ¿El hecho de que las mujeres tienden a ser
mucho menos violentas que los hombres? Pero no, no era ninguno de esos dones.
Dijeron, "La habilidad de procrear."
Dije, "Ay, vamos. O sea, incluso si las mujeres trataran de tener un bebé
todos los años desde que cumplen 15 años hasta que tienen 45,
asumiendo que no muriesen de cansancio,
podría ser que algunas mujeres tuvieran tiempo de sobra
para escuchar la palabra de Dios." Y dijeron, "No."
(Risas)
Para entonces ya no me parecían tan lindos,
pero tenían más que decir.
Dijeron, "Bueno, también creemos que si eres mormón
y te llevas bien con la iglesia, cuando mueres
vas al cielo y estás con tu familia para toda la eternidad."
Y dije, "¡Oh, cielos!--
(Risas)
-- eso no sería un buen incentivo para mi."
Y dijeron, "Ah -- pero también creemos
que cuando te vas al cielo tu cuerpo es restaurado
a su estado original.
Por ejemplo, si perdiste una pierna, la recuperas.
O si te quedaste ciego, puedes ver."
Dije, "Oh -- Yo no tengo útero porque tuve cáncer
hace unos años. Entonces, eso significa que si me voy al cielo
recuperaré mi útero?" Y dijeron, "Desde luego."
Y dije, "No lo quiero de vuelta, soy feliz sin él." ¡Cielos!
¿Y qué si te operaste la nariz y te gustó?
(Risas)
¿Dios te obligaría a recuperar tu vieja nariz?
Entonces me dieron el Libro de Mormón.
y me dijeron que leyera este capítulo y aquél,
dijeron que volverían un día a ver cómo iba,
y creo que dije algo como, "No se apuren,"
o tal vez sólo, "Por favor, no," y se fueron.
Entonces, al principio me sentía superior a estos chicos,
y estaba satisfecha con mi fe más convencional. Pero entonces,
mientras más lo pensaba, más honesta tenía que ser conmigo misma.
Si alguien viniera a mi puerta y me pusiera a escuchar teología y dogmas
católicos por primera vez, y me dijeran,
"Creemos que Dios embarazó a una niña muy joven
sin relaciones coitales,
y el hecho de que ella fuera virgen es maniáticamente importante para nosotros--
(Risas)
-- y ella tuvo un bebé, que es el hijo de Dios."
Lo vería igualmente ridículo.
Sólo que estoy tan acostumbrada a esa historia.
(Risas)
Así que no pude permitirme ser condescendiente con esos chicos.
Pero lo que me preguntaron cuando llegaron
realmente se quedó en mi cabeza:
¿Creo que Dios me ama con todo su corazón?
Porque no estaba segura sobre cómo me sentía al respecto.
Si me hubieran preguntado,
¿Sientes que Dios te ama con todo su corazón?
Bueno, eso habría sido muy diferente, creo que habría respondido inmediatamente,
"Sí, sí lo siento todo el tiempo. Siento el amor de Dios cuando estoy confundida y herida,
me siento consolada, me refugio en el amor de Dios
cuando no entiendo por qué ocurren las tragedias,
y siento el amor de dios cuando miro con gratitud toda la belleza que veo."
Pero como me preguntaron con la palabra creer en la pregunta,
de alguna forma todo fue diferente,
porque no estaba segura si creía lo que tan claramente sentía.